In this example there were several lines we couldn't really tell whether or
not it should be included in the final file.
This is because it could've been added by one person or
they could have been removed by the other and we couldn't tell which was which.
How could we solve this problem?
Well, it would definitely help to know what the file looked like at
the beginning of the day.
If the original file looked like this, with the lines A, B and D,
could we then determine for these unknowns whether or not they should appear?
Again, this is a hard question.
Here's how I would go about it.
For each line that's in Jake's file, but not in Rachel's, I would try to figure
out whether Jake added the chore, or whether Rachel removed it, and vice versa